genau eine woche ist es her seit die
ukraine ihre großoffensive im osten des
landes gestartet hat und wir wollen uns
einmal die karte ansehen wie sie nämlich
eine woche später jetzt aussieht wir
erinnern uns die region raki 4 im
nordosten des landes rund um die
millionenstadt 1,4 millionen einwohner
attraktiv war seit märz unter russischer
kontrolle riesige gebiete hier standen
komplett unter russischer kontrolle ein
gebiet von etwa 7.000 quadratkilometern
also fast drei mal so groß wie das
saarland dieser gebiete wurden jetzt
befreit und was die ukraine dort alles
finden für waffen die russen benutzt
haben in den städten wie sie um und kubi
angst vor allem das ist schon
bemerkenswert und das wollen wir uns
einmal ansehen
aufnahmen aus der stadt easy um von
ukrainern zeigen hier zum ersten mal
eine thermo bayerische waffe vom typ toz
1 a hier sehen sie hier vielleicht ganz
gut erst mal liegen und gleich nochmal
von namen das ist diese waffe die diese
aerosole bomben ab schießt also diese
bomben ab schießt die zusammen mit der
luft und einem chemischen gemisch mega
explosion und einem extrem starken
unterdruck entwickeln und so zum tod von
hunderten ukraine geführt haben wir
sehen uns hier noch mal aus der nähe
hier also der ja wenn man so möchte der
der gefechts teil dieses waffensystem
ist wir sehen hier also wie schon einige
dieser dieser rohre dort leer sind und
aus anderen gucken noch die raketen raus
und einige meter weiter und das ist eben
kaum zu glauben nämlich da hinten da
hinten steht der unter teil von diesem
waffensystem das heißt auch das scheint
in den letzten tagen oder sogar wochen
von den ukrainern getroffen worden zu
sein ist dann auseinander geflogen und
explodiert und man kann es sich nur
vorstellen an der völlig verbrannten
erde an den verbrannten steinen auch die
man hier sieht wie extrem diese thermo
bayerische explosion hier gewesen sein
muss als dieser top 1a dort explodiert
ist und daneben ja und dann eben in
seine einzelteile dort zerfallen ist das
also in easy um von der ukrainischen
armee gefunden in kopie an keiner
anderen großstadt hat die ukrainische
armee auch unfassbares entdeckt nämlich
zum ersten mal
iranische kamikaze drohnen die hier
offenbar von der russischen armee
benutzt wurde eine von denen wurde
offenbar auf die ukraine abgeschlossen
als sie die stadt schon erobert hatten
einige fotos davon an und am ende ein
foto aus dem iran so um das zu
vergleichen das also die shahid 136 von
der iss vor einem monat etwa hieß aus
amerikanischen quellen die sei
mittlerweile von russland gekauft worden
und sollte in der ukraine eingesetzt
werden und wir schauen uns das hier noch
mal an das hier ist so eine
abschussvorrichtung mit mehreren davon
und wir sehen dass es nicht die ukraine
sondern hier oben das ist die iranische
wüste wo also in der iranischen wüste
bei einem militärmanöver die geprüft
wurden und wir schauen uns vor allem
diese regionen hinten einmal
quasi um das und um das seitenruder
dieser dieser drohne dieser kamikaze
drohne und wir sehen daneben dass diese
drohne tatsächlich genau die ist die
jetzt in koblenz gefunden wurde da sehen
was auf der einen seite und hier sehen
wir das gleich auf der anderen seite der
ukrainische geheimdienst untersucht das
gerade und möchte feststellen ob
tatsächlich die mullahs putins regime
jetzt hier kamikaze drogen geliefert
haben so sieht es zumindest aus
wir haben gesagt dass die region raki
befreit wurde interessanterweise ist es
noch lange nicht zu ende damit mit der
ukrainischen offensive sondern wir
gucken mal hier in süden hier ist da die
region donetsk südlich von easy um und
da wurde die stadt wird hier ist gestern
von ukrainischen truppen befreit auch
dort gab es kaum kämpfe auch dort haben
sich die russen zurückgezogen und wir
sehen uns das ganze mal an hier also
erste videoaufnahmen auswerten hier ist
die stadt die lvr vor zwei monaten erst
verloren wurde an die russische armee
nach schweren kämpfen hier sehen wir
dass das stimmt was auch immer
nachdenken kann studios steht hier auf
kyrillisch und die ukrainischen soldaten
gingen jetzt sollte ihre flagge an und
sind extrem glück nicht dass sie auch
dort zurückkommen konnten wir sehen eine
großflächige zerstörung das auch eine
relativ große stadt mit großen häusern
mehrstöckigen häusern die alle zerstört
wurden durch die russische angriffe und
natürlich dann auch durch die schweren
kämpfe nachdem die russische armee diese
stadt erobert hatte zu guter letzt
wollen wir uns wieder die neuen
westlichen waffen ansehen die in die
ukraine kommen und wir haben ganz
aktuelle aufnahmen hier von einem
sogenannten ketten panzer aus
großbritannien und zwar dem spaten fv
103 der eben in diesem video zu sehen
ist chronische soldaten sind also hier
darauf bewegen sich voran und aus
verschiedenen perspektiven wurde dieser
konvoi gezeigt hier sehen wir es noch
mal das ist also der sparten fv 103 ein
britischer ketten panzer der bis 1995
etwa im dienste der britischen armee
stand seitdem mehr und mehr ausgemustert
wird und wir sehen es hier noch einmal
am ende gleich mehrere davon man sagt
bis zu 20 30 stück hat großbritannien
der ukraine zur verfügung gestellt
während deutschland sagt es gibt
angeblich eine abmachung unter
nato-ländern der ukraine eben genau
solche fahrzeuge also ketten panzer
nicht zur verfügung zu stellen das
scheint nicht so stimmen wir sehen
mittlerweile westlichen nato ketten
panzer hier auch in der region tief im
osten
[Musik]